ce soir comme on va parler d'amour un
petit peu et que jean michel maire
j'aimerais vous moi vous me racontez
cette équipe votre premier amour
alors mon premier amour est appelée
giovanni giovanni way apparemment
c'était un allemand vous avez tellement
voilà on avait 16 en effet trois ans
ensemble non et voilà c'est la grande
amour quoi c'est vrai ouais vous l'avez
revu depuis
c'est un pote à moi non et ça et ça
replonge jamais jamais jamais de la vie
voit ses rêves ou qu'enseignant je lui
ai dit il était à la mode à voir
maintenant il espère un vote non ça
l'est déjà dit ah ouais et vous vous
aiguiller les mariés il a une femme et
un enfant non et ça vous a pas fait un
petit pansement que rien du tout
n'aurait dû tourner d'amoureux de
durrenbach cette pêche aux commandes
comme et ou au lycée au lycée dans mon
école
ouais bah dans la cour ouais dans les
couloirs n'ont trouvé en train de fumer
dans les toilettes de l'établissement
sans rigoler parce que kelly agathe on
voit ces les meubles jour à mon avis l
école elle devait avoir un succès des
offres aux cayes a aussi même si c'est
vrai si si si si à mon avis c'est bête
les meufs vaut aussi
non mais sans révéler beaucoup de succès
mais je sais je me rappelle moi je
recevais des télégrammes brive l2 mais
quand il a pu choquer lille devait être
mais pas comme un ouf parce que le
premier truc que tu as envie de faire
quand tu peux sauter une meuf de ouf
appelle tes copains on dit bon ça y est
je les pêches aux frères effet strauss
le mec il a dû à compenser qu'il a fait
ce à quoi je m'attendais mais vous tous
les lycées voulez-vous pécho donc
peut-être peut-être mais surtout pas
giovanni comme ça la sonorité je trouve
dégueulasse mais le même benjamin
castaldi
alors mon chéri quand c'est qu'il est
quito premières amours elle s'appelait
lucie brossette lucie brossette
et oui eh ben vous l'avez moi c'est non
c'était en 5e j'étais quand même tout
petit et je sais que je vais retrouver
pour baba noël ouais c'est vrai je suis
tombé malade
non mais c'est vrai je l'avais retrouvé
pour baba noël et vous êtes tombé malade
vraiment le mon amour de d'enfants quoi
et qui a été grand et des bêtes est
blonde
ah oui déjà blonde était grande a été
belle était bon et ben a été belle
sincérité ses textes à l'islam au nom
des autres blancs non c'est vrai et
alors est comment c'est fini mais en
fait elle à laquelle a quitté le collège
est jamais revu
j'ai un bac je voulais retrouver je
voulais amènera un jour il faut iphone
et vous avez bah moi je n'ai pas vu mais
paraît qu'elle est toujours très joli
c'est vrai apparemment et un cinquième
mariage
[Applaudissements]
premier amour t'es qui je suis tout
petit c'est un garçon de mon immeuble
qui s'appelait in chang et en fait on
est du shangdong d'accord ni d'accord on
est professeur phil immeuble alti fait
en fait on l'adorait occuper une chambre
ont aidé plusieurs en tout cas sur le
coup et en fait comme dans ma lancée
changer régulièrement des plats on se
débrouille et toujours pour user pour
être la fille qui va ramener le plat à
sa maman pour lui parler
qu'en attendez vous habitiez dans un
restaurant non on a vite envahi le très
convivial on sait quoi tu peux tu dis
des bêtises
zhang non mais c'est qu'elle a sous la
dent bracine des petites non non non non
j'étais vraiment petit chameau genre
voilà oui voilà c'était le petit beau
gosse de l'immeuble quoi mais on peut
aussi très bien vous avez envie de
revoir enfin pourquoi pas on va le
retrouver une chance dans ce cas là la
bourgade manifeste toi sur les réseaux
sociaux va te retrouver une chance voilà
à gâteau proulx est là
ce que tu votre premier amour c'était
charles charras ouais alors là c'était
premiers de la classe la charge ou pas
du tout j'arrivais en seconde et
redoublait sa terminale
non c'était un peu le bad boy du lycée
ont toutes les filles et mes biens est
en fait un de ses très bons copains
avaient flashé sur moi quand j'étais
arrivé au lycée
donc c'était un peu compliqué pour lui
mais il a fini par lui dire écoute la
schl à faire tu vois cette fille je veux
sortir avec elle et ça va durer toute la
vie
bon donc moi ça m'a charmé de ouf
apparemment il n'était pas claude alexis
et en fait on est resté le dos alors pas
du tout vraiment on est resté toutes mes
années lycée je suis resté toutes mes
années lycée avec lyon avec charles avec
charles absolument et il était très
convoité donc je recevais des des
lettres de ses ex dans ma boîte aux
lettres donc de chez ma maman bobo et ça
ne marchera pas avec charles nom et vous
l'avez revue change non pas depuis qu'on
s'est séparé vous êtes séparés ya
combien de temps bah quand j'avais 18
ans donc il ya cette version certes
yamaha côté vous avez 25 ou 26 maman 26
babin c'est que ça pousse on voit pas le
temps passer et vous pourriez reprendre
avec charme pas mais qu'il sûr que non
et pourquoi ce serait sympathique sans
uv mais non mais une histoire une fois
qu'elle est finie une fois que l'amour
est parti et benjamin castadi une fois
que la mort partie 1 aux tab puis tenus
c'est comme un boomerang c'est un
nouveau mannequin jade dort j'aime
j'aime pas me remettre le couvert oui on
peut rester ami avec ses exploits dans
mettre vos atouts
bah ouais bah oui qui est ami avec ses
ex alors bon ceux qui sont vivants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maxime guémy soit il s'appelait clémence
non clé morges allait avoir 18 ans a
rencontré en première de ma classe
non c'est vrai c'est vrai et puis ça a
duré quatre ans non quatre ans habitait
ensemble voter ensemble à paris mais
vous avez tout fait mais il a connu la
conçoit dans maman 1
il ya eu quatre fois non il avait couché
avec la personne non c'est juste ok vous
êtes comme monfils oui et alors il se
pose c'est fini est parti vers de
nouvelles aventures ont fui vers de
nouvelles d'elle n'avait pas un petit
peu voir si on n'est pas un peu là-bas
elle elle a eu l'honnêteté de me dire
voilà on passe à autre chose un malade
du 3 la connais elle a connu de tous et
c'est un peu c'est un peu fort de café
voilà merci albert celle gringo
[Applaudissements]
il permet la fin
alors allemands de l'est a réparé il
faisait nuit sur ces la baisse oui alors
nous sommes en 1972 avait à villiers sur
orge un petit village de l'essonne
ouais j'ai 8 ans ouais je suis en co2 et
je suis amoureux fou de nathalie c'est
la fille de la maîtresse pour vous la
décrire physiquement c'est entre julia
roberts est allé berry d'accord c'est un
mix des deux c'est ouais c'est un aller
robert elle est sublime et j'arrive pas
encore le physique que j'ai aujourd'hui
hanifi et je suis sûr que petit vous
étiez très très beau concert mais
cresson la laiterie ce mois ci ont le
label or on a les plus ingrats notre
problème de nathalie s'est calé mais
bruno eyron je me démonte pas le gage
sait où il habite
oui résidence du parc à quelle mémoire
et de la police là je dis je vais y
aller je lui dis tout touche plus à
nathalie j vais-je le choc au pied sont
ni objet bruno tu touches pierre attali
et déjà cette fois annoncé deux
exactement déserteurs et fait 6 passes
et à taez et là je suis fait peur et là
bruno me peux te le dis exactement il
m'en avait une bonne pas
et donc à terminer j'ai plus regardées
nathalie quoi ils peuvent être toujours
en sortant maltraitance parce que il
s'appelle moribond
alors à moi c'était platonique parce que
j'avais 12 ans mais c'était le premier
garçon qui m'a provoqué un petit truc
nanterre où il avait des tâches des
taches de rousseur mme sawyer il et
voilà qu'en mai où je n'étais pas là oui
en tout cas c'est atteint espagnac en
lozère ah oui moi je faisais pas alors
je n'osais d'autant moindre gates était
tout maigre et j'avais des cheveux tout
freezer aurait bien une morille un
champignon maury et un jour il m'a mise
en grille fils de sauter d'un petit pont
il y en a plein en lozère et donc moi je
me dois donc la personne voulait se
débarrasser de vous sentez et là j'ai
cru que le bas du corps rentrer dans le
haut parce que pousse en arrivant mais
ça ça fait un effet et en plus il y
avait un espèce de petit mollusque ses
piquants s'en approcher exactement à
l'endroit où le service était un petit
mollusque qui en asie vous souhaitez
dans l'ariège
et ouais c'est 6 dans l'eau pendant que
lui il partait à la fois brûlé humilié
et c'est une aventure qui manquait pas
de piquant même si c'est rien passé
s'est couchée sans être amoureuse donc
ça a rétabli les tice
après la guerre les a séparés après la
guerre les a séparés t'as pas une
nouvelle
vendredi les fatiguer lui fait même pas
le shabbat des mauvaises bases
[Applaudissements]